oh right that was fast and I'd love that
too flashpoint EEB artists what's going
on man oh I've got a little workout in
hyped as ever basically at this point
kind of loving life right now but we've
got a lot to look forward to and I don't
know they've done really really well so
far and kind of digging it yeah this is
hype season like we're going to cusps no
man what is it two weeks yeah yeah man
it's really close we're getting close
but a lot of information has dropped a
lot of stuff to get into been playing a
lot of destiny recently and yeah pretty
much solstices Oh is almost done I just
got to get that uh I mean the Solstice
purple stuff is done for me I just gotta
get my what's called math towards the
chest piece it was the prestige read and
I had a plan to do it yesterday but
couple frog claming state needed the
normal prestige I mean the normal
Leviathan so I thought I'm a bone so he
kind of noobs through but it was fun I
got to get mine done hopefully this
weekend
so I can put that thing to bed for ya
man we got a lot to discuss it is man is
some stuff I want to get into it about
wait for certain parts so so if you guys
have not seen and it is your option to
watch if you're following the game
closely enough to basically be involved
as we are you probably know what happens
the Kade through the story it's kind of
motivation we know what's going on but
they dropped it really really awesome
cinematic just give us a highlight and
it's one of those that you will see if
you play the story so feel free to wait
the 10 days before this thing comes out
or you can check it out and watch it
again in the story either way I don't
think it takes away from anything
personally to watch it now because we
already know but it's just like I can
watch this thing like three times in a
row and just love it every time so I
thought it was like one of the cooler
exotics I think you brought up the taken
King one when we were talking earlier
and you've got a point like I speak as
you said this highlights one person
really really well which they don't do
fantastic yeah
then you've got the taking king for the
overall like the epic scale of that
opening video yeah that one still can I
kick some life balance a which of it I
which II like you know when I saw this I
guess I guess a when we spoke offline
before I'm always super critical you
know especially like when it comes to my
Marvel movies and things of greatness
and this is just comparing like you said
Leo Ferrari to Lamborghini it's personal
preference it's what she's like
as far as character trailer it's no
doubt like this is the greatest
character focused trailer in my opinion
in Destiny's history as far as I you
know as far as scope I always have a
soft place for thinking cuz taken king
represents change taken King represents
that turning point that golden era of
you know destinies to be taken seriously
you know because the community up into
that point what kind of beating down
like you know based on how destiny one
started so and then obviously had more
solve we had to take a gig get all this
stuff going on but man what a salute to
the gunslinger me like I was in my
fields during that cage I do so let's
just say updated teased in there as well
if you get where I'm I love that part of
it I was like yeah oh just like cannot
wait to get my hands on this Lake mm-hmm
yeah I was like in chat shoutouts and
plumbing welcome joining us early but
yeah it's like everybody you know what's
going on sad about it but man I will say
they are are doing service to him pretty
well house watch that cinematic watch it
four times over watch it on the TV with
compare rounds have like just you know
have a little fun with it enjoy it it's
won't say much more than that in case
you do want to hold tight but that's
pretty easily yes sir
now the other thing they dropped in
games come besides just talking about
general stuff we probably already knew
from e3 and isn't that gambit is going
to get a free trial so I'm gonna play a
quick little teaser let's go you guys
can see what's coming
hold on
I have no sound my bad all good all good
get the visual The Drifter okay
smoke so much fun man I cannot wait for
you guys to get a chance to experience
this so first I was like that's the one
piece you may not have quite caught
because it goes so quick so fast yeah so
24-hour preview mm-hmm everyone if you
own any version of destiny - at all
even if it's just year one with no
expansions you are going to get to play
gambit for free for 24 hours so it's
Saturday September 1st 12 o'clock
Central Time
what unlocked for you 10 a.m. Pacific
all those goodies 24 hours so if you're
gonna be at home boot this game up and
test it out because you get to try the
new mode without asking anything so I
don't know man
I just the more I sit here and watch
like the trailer and think about this
the more I'm wondering how deep this
mode is going to be like I said I can't
wait for you to get him if I'm lucky
let's go go down like this this is this
is it's really a fantastic mode I mean
it serves that that itch that pvp and
PVE itch and everyone can have a roll
and it's gonna be people who don't even
care about the pv part and the mode is
still fun like it's still good you know
what the blockers the modes
saving most is gonna be strategies with
that and then I like that there's gonna
be unique gear and ranking systems tied
to it so I cannot wait for you to get
over it this is gonna be a fun one love
the way they're doing this and let's
give it credit credit like at the end of
the day like
giving the the base something to play
that don't that you know maybe on the
fence what forsaken and you know just
letting them touch this is great
marketing so I really like it you know
it's some really really smart move I
mean this is one of your new sellers
people know about PBE people know about
PvP but gamba they're like here's this
new mode
I have destiny to I don't really want to
buy the you know I'm not sure as you
said you're on the fence fence sitters
right in there they're not they're just
literally boot it up you know update
your patch like you know in the next
couple of days and you know in the next
week or so and then come September first
check it out see if it's one of those
things that's gonna give you something
to go for so absolutely man absolutely
shout out to the dude in tower dude
fantastic last night man shot you in
pink lemonade these guys run a great
show I swear flashpoint Alatorre gonna
have to do something at that point now
someone's got to get on someone show at
this point because he's a to I become a
destiny podcast but y'all shout to them
man oh short pause those guys do a
fantastic job I listened to them last
night it was really good man and we
can't wait to dive into this kaback
content as well man such a lot of stuff
to talk about sweet so yeah
September 1st definitely spend some time
in there I'm gonna be in there a lot
because honestly it's after the 28th I
mean I'm gonna be testing out the
weapons messing with my fault stuff like
that for actually things to light link
Soulstice is done there's not a lot to
grind for so like you know and I feel
everything out spend some time feel out
your builds and have some fun and this
is one where I was looking at what's up
TJ marks I'm on my comments like when I
see the bubble in the end that wakes
honestly makes me think of how you're
gonna play like if you worried of the
primeval dying and giving or actually
dying when the Prime Evils up is getting
its health back this is yes play safe
and cautious to make sure you don't get
picked off somebody's got heavy though
they can play the hard shot you stay in
the bubble play it safe with the new
little boost we'll talk about a bit
later like there has potential for other
classes now and there's so many
different things ya the support classes
yeah absolutely support the support
class has benefit
you know and I can't wait you know to
see like I said I've tried best around
with the UM the new dawn blade super
fantastic obviously you know we know the
nine supers that are coming there's
gonna be so many strategic elements
going on I cannot wait oh yeah I mean
I'm just sitting here thinking in my
head like bubble if you need to like
hold down the front point or somebody
could just be in a bubble be taking down
the and always have like a ward of dawn
with name fourteen on there I come in
just stand-in there with a shotgun
melt and get done just keep you out so
you run and dump them easy but also
think about like a hunter with the traps
and you got three shots yes traps around
the map so if anybody does invade when
you're melting the primeval they might
get done with another like you could do
a lot of I mean yeah you did dirty with
it where I like I was like that's man
it's good old suppression grenades I'm
still gonna hate him though oh yeah
brushing your nails tractor cannon those
abilities so help I by Peter so
disrespectful I mean so this is honestly
the best part of my day of reading this
this was huge and also I think this is a
sign of how much is to come let's go so
about that time they said many of you
have been reaching out questions to know
exactly we're gonna start hunting Aldrin
and his barons and things like that on
September 4th will come down for
maintenance that morning at 7 a.m.
Pacific I mean it should end around 10
a.m. Pacific if you have your download
done at that point you should be able to
log in you know for me it should be
right around noon Central Time so well I
get in at noon just like any other reset
only problem with me is I can't do a
reset and play at the same time so a
reset video pretty much falls off and
every because I don't even know what to
tell them yet I'm like I'm not sure any
mm-hmm
sorry I had to mute first knees you
didn't want to do that
so never get out now the next piece Joe
Malak Burton comes in forsaken us proof
that full full the full destiny to
experience is just the beginning when
the campaign comes to
clothes which from what I've heard and
there's leaks and things out there this
is gonna hopefully tie in really well
get attic that it'll act like some happy
people happy people man happy people
what that sentence right there actually
pleased me a lot because that's what we
want we want that continuity from
campaign to rate continue it's like it's
just the beginning it's like everything
else is like yeah okay there's like
strikes to run and you grind it out it's
like you're just getting going which is
awesome
there's so many new things to do so much
power to gain we knew that players would
need a chance more than just three days
to prepare for the incredible challenge
I didn't even have to read anything else
I was like more than three days that's
to have you at that point that live he
thought this was a happy way and that's
why at last wish we'll get to that a
little later that is the name of the
raid the next chapter of Dusty's rating
legacy goes live on September 14th ten
days on a Friday so good yeah go for it
continue no just a week and a half after
you fit after you first stepped foot on
tangled Shore good luck and then we've
got basically the door that you've
probably seen that is where we will
travel through like ten days we were
saying this a lot of people have been
hoping oh this is exactly what I wanted
to hear I am I am so psyched yeah it's
really cool cuz like I said we don't
have to go crazy Russian we have time
explore the content you know and I know
some people you know the hardcore may be
you know a little upset like oh you know
I'm gonna be so over leveled you know by
the time next week or whatever but
there's you know there's ton of people
who don't have the time to please please
you got a no life it for three days
really like to be one of the dedicated
you pretty much have to do this as a job
like take time off of work you know
again it doesn't put as much pressure on
people to have to do it so I am
definitely liking this I can enjoy the
content and then I can't wait we get to
see what's behind that magic door what's
going on in there supposedly the most
bosses they had hinted at before and
yeah this this is this is gonna be the
one I'm very excited about this rate
thank God we retire a Leviathan
no more apartment 2b and
get a full raid let's go
so hey now there still will be layers
they say to this that's they have ones
they have mentioned that bring you back
to earth
no but picture if they continue building
on that it's gotta be done right it's
gotta be done again it's gotta be tied
into that first end is at a paragraph
continuity like it's got a continuum so
think about the ascendant realm yeah
that's what if you have different
variations you know or you do like
different weekly row to something like
that like I know they can do a lot with
it if it keeps pushing the campaign
farther and farther like then like if it
as you said it's just like it's a
literally a cabal ship and all of a
sudden you're like here's this VEX thing
in the dumpster like if you break it
down I mean that's obviously that's what
it was layman's terms but I mean that's
where you break down and you lose this
whole connection I mean Alice was far
enough there was like literally one
adventure and as I've been doing all the
damage ventures in this game recently
for the Soulstice armor I've done all of
them now there's literally one you hear
about this dude callous like halt you
know any talks about the you know life
of a plenty he they phrased it
differently but I mean you get to see it
later from him cuz he's this big fat-ass
slob and stuff like that but but I mean
that's it's designed for games and plush
and all this stuff
you're like how does the hell does this
fit in the Gaul like where this dude who
is like the tone like the speaker
getting just what you see
Goll trying to like take the light from
the traveler wanting to be this
all-powerful like universal ruler type
and then you go to be like yeah just you
know come play my complaint like wake up
this game show and we're gonna I'm gonna
test your skill and you know I actually
like the cool thing at the end with you
know revealing obvious if you haven't
finished by now come on spoil yeah but
like you know was it him it was kind of
like a you know the robot test or
whatever but you know at the end of the
day it's just like we didn't get any
closure I don't know who was it cow or
is who tell is that hello
start spire the stars yes by the Stars
and it's just like it just didn't fit
narrative ly it just didn't make any
sense
and on top of that we had in in between
we had you know Osiris that you know the
campaign that didn't connect we had you
know Anna Bray whose campaign didn't
connect to Leviathan so I'm hoping and
what I'm very confident now at least
with this is that there will be
connection we're not going off to a
separate place and I remember the devs
are saying that you know the Dreaming
city is going to change you know so
after maybe a certain time the race
completed you know it changes and it
affects you know what's going on in
there or whatever and we can lucky
hopeful like you said maybe some type of
ascendant realm kind of thing but I'm in
agreement with you
you know Leviathan was not handled well
the first Leviathan I was okay with but
spire stars either of worlds although
they're you know gameplay-wise
systematically decent raids you know
I'll be short it just didn't fit
narrative Lee yeah no I agree and
honestly what they really really have
got to do in this one I want to see
personally mmm-hmm give me a damn raid
cinematic oh please yes that you have to
explain where the hell this comes from
or if you're gonna do some disjointed
thing especially like Leviathan which I
hope they don't but I mean have a reason
have an explanation have a backstory of
how in the world did Argos end up in
that yes a couple planet he got stuck in
there he ate everything he finally grew
up and now he's this jet like witness
where the hell he came from like
something Paula masks arranged who is
kal-el what does he have to do what is
he gonna take her freak alice is here um
a second general like who the hell is
this dude's market on he's a target in
my sights until he dies that's all I
know that's all it is oh good we go on
it all about race yeah like I mean that
sounds like plummy an inch at Calais is
an interesting character it's like give
me some background on him like what is
the deal like won't give me some more
like rendered this damn ship out and see
a driving around the universe and be
like here's a Galaxy home exactly like
it's kind of crazy so
I want to know more and I know Loulou
like this type of cinematic level for a
character awesome have pay blur studios
cuz that's who did the last one and just
dude pay them another set like for the
raid like I want that level or and it
doesn't even have to be four minutes
long that's a lot right for an intro but
give me like a quick backstory like
here's this ship it's following him he's
trying to follow like and all to catch
up to him and we're in this universe and
he's here now and it's like us or them
so completely ugly yeah give us a reason
it's our a random tangent no no it's a
great tangent because at the end of day
and I'm just I'll be short man it's just
that even they like the concept is dope
right like the love I didn't like I'm a
transformers kid so you know from me the
Leviathan was almost like a Unicron
thing this planet either you know it's
people are in trouble you know then give
some back story with callous you know I
understand Gaul kind of overthrew I get
that part you know him and they're not
it calls out the way just give us more
context you know what's going on
especially when you end the raid like
that there was no sense of what we did
this for and what happens next at least
any type of cryptic thing so that they
just got to work on their and I am
confident that they will not pull the
mistake negatively that they did with
Leviathan so let's go man I'm thinking
positive and my boy Milan is over there
you know he stressed all those points I
know they got him working on a grimoire
book and all that stuff but you know it
seems to be that they are trying to take
law in the right direction so I'm
hopeful yeah it seems like it's getting
there just as you said have to wait and
see
so yeah ten days enjoy this is one of
those times like an actual today
normally for a forsake it like any
expansion I'd be like take your time if
you're not one of those who is really
going for worlds first enjoy it now you
really can kind of do both you have a
week and a half probably gonna play a
lot no matter what but you can still get
some sleep in there oh absolutely
all right guys next piece as we've all
been wondering about they answer quite a
few questions about mods they go into
detail about you know where you're gonna
be getting from what you're gonna do
with your old ones which you forgot them
stock piled up all that type of thing so
we know mods with you watched the combat
reveal stream
they had a bunch of them they're not
meant to be that as abundant as we
probably feel they are right now like we
just can go in there by some not like
they're pretty common right want these
to be more rare so if you don't have
quite as many of them or if you use them
up and you're like hey they're a little
harder to get ahold of that's kind of
the point
mods are supposed to they want them to
mean more therefore be a bit more rare
as that stuff should be right some of
the ways literally but you're gonna get
them in year two so all exotic armor
drops regardless of the year we'll have
a chance to come with an equipped mod
which is good if you get duplicates then
you'll actually have a benefit to
potentially glad when you break enough
good point good point though a little
benefit to your third or fourteenth best
for the radius or whatever like yeah so
they say well I did your tenth better
Devils more interesting let me stop we
stuff those odds continued non-raid your
two legendary weapons and armor drops
we'll have a small chance to come
equipped with mod so this is one thing I
have a question on which in LOB's looked
like it came when you level 10 master
worked it okay yep so how is just a non
rate just a random legendary weapon
gonna come with a mod does the master
work just like boost the stats or give
you that extra slot that's kind of one
of those things I was wondering about
yeah I remember when we watched the
combat stream whenever they master what
you seen the let's say for example if it
was like a master work to range you
would see it slightly increase each time
you master worked up a level yeah so I
remember saying that once they got to
ten that's when I thought like the mod
slide opened the next like tears that's
where I thought that came so that's why
I'm kind of wondering how this works
yeah it's interesting we see a one
legendary armor mod always drops one
more component when dismantled oh yeah
this is this is this is very interested
in and I want to shout out at itok they
actually mention this too like the as we
continue to read like the armor is gonna
hold two slots kind of thing and it's
it's interesting to see how they are
handling that as far as opposed to the
the weapon mod slot because it's still
holding like the old one in the in the
armor set okay so you're free to keep
the weapon you know or
and that's the thing you can override a
mod or if you break that weapon down
it's a crappy roll you can take the mod
out so giving your duplicates will have
it even more benefit to be like you know
is this roll good or does this have a
mod that I really want and especially
early on I wouldn't worry quite as much
it's kind of one of those pieces of
advice as you guys are going through
leveling up don't worry about breaking
things apart too much like just hold on
to stuff you're gonna have a little bit
more space see what your real optimal
stuff is you may think like and this may
be mediocre but I do like the gun I mean
you don't get anything better you can
infuse it level it up and so a decent
model ready so absolutely I wouldn't
like just really try and optimize her
min max to fast
take your time that's gonna come later
absolutely you may pull mods out of gear
used for other gear by dismantling
alternately if you want to leave it in
there you can choose a new mod over the
other one so you can overwrite or take
it out if you dismantle so those are
like big-time yeah I was like I like
that if you put one in but you're like
hey I'm done with this gun pull it out
if they're really that rare that's good
yeah that was a problem I'm one of the
few that actually played extensively
with you know the mod system indeed some
dude has it started and it sucked like
you break something down that you had
kind of like a speck towards whether it
be grenade recharge class item you know
and just to break and just lose the mod
completely kind of sucks so to see that
happen and you retain something and also
it gives value to weapons that you don't
care about but have a good mod so you're
like okay I'll break this down sigh no
I'm gonna get you know something I'm
gonna use in the future towards
something else I want to use so I love
that aspect of what they're doing
the good thing though vendors do not
come with mods so I mean if you're
buying a specific gun you might go for a
random role on a different week but you
are gonna have some audit so you just
can't you know vendor yeah it company
over and just like Phillip I'm not so so
if you have mod components in glimmer
necessary to feel you have feed the
habit you may go to straight to banshee
so for all of your mods you have now
don't break them down yet you can and I
think mod components are really what
you're gonna use to buy them right
that's gonna put honestly if you wait to
the first time mods are just gonna be
like just figure them out when you need
them you know breaks them down as you go
you'll have some space so direct by year
to armor mod and you'll be up to be able
to buy one of those
daily and then or at least it'll be
updated daily and then also one weapon
mods who's gonna weapon an ARMA mod that
you can straight up just by so got a lot
of them saved up like some of us do I
have a buttload of legendary ones I'm
probably going to be able to buy some
for a little while but as we keep
progressing and going then you know
you'll still eventually run out of stuff
yeah for armor your to armor mods always
drop one mug component when dismantled
your one legendary armor mods always
drop one mod component when dismantled
so if you break down a legend there
you're gonna get a component rare armor
mods so chance
yes I'm such a same thing with same
thing with weapons if it's legendary
you're gonna mod component so that you
can go buy another one so you got
something you don't like bring it down
and go buy something else sounds good
also for year one armor mods all your
year one armor mods in your inventory
will cease to work just not gonna long
him yes so they literally phasing these
things out yep and you can dismantle
them for the materials if you break down
a whole bunch of blue is obvious you may
not get that much your one armor mods
currently slot into your one armor will
cease to work that is armor specifically
remember the weapon mods the bead damage
type will lock in also remember that so
before the 28th if you got some time
this weekend you want to go check the
reddit thread that's got all the data
farming for what things are gonna lock
in to sure happy do you know your main
happy weapons where you want them
exactly
year two armor mods will be able to be
slotted into both year one and year two
armor mod slots so that's what you were
talking about its unless he's got two
slots yes this isn't you're staying
honest interesting which gives all my
little a little flexibility which thank
God no no this is so deadly and I know
you've got to go on your reign right now
I've done that enough if we got options
we got rolls on armor and multiple
options then yes absolutely absolutely
that's the with mods yep
Josh Hamrick is like I'm gonna be
invading your gambit games real real
quick like will be around this weekend
yes sir so they are giving us a sneak
peek for you know
or next week here we go you know
discussing some of the stuff yes yes yes
yes I am changes now as you look through
this it's actually no no I was gonna say
I was looking through this and tell me
if I'm wrong there's specifically not a
ton of change than this maybe again a
forsaken change not this week right
there's not a ton of changes
specifically to some errors then sorry
yeah so you've got abilities in exotics
which is fine so hunters your market is
now considered a reload and it can
interact with kill clip racking which is
actually really good so like cattle clip
especially just got a bit more busier
because if you're like kill good to go
that's almost even faster
exactly I'm picturing scared and now
hunters would run around with an e hopes
and oh do anything you know and that's
considered a real oh now with the dodge
Hey oh yeah
celestial Nighthawk will grant 33% of
your super energy back if a target is
killed by the Golden Gun that's actually
not bad
I'm almost like if you're gonna blow
celestial Nighthawk on one like saying
the Clovis strike you're like this mini
boss just needs to get vaporized it's
nice to get some back mm-hmm
worm has crown oh yes worm HUS crown
will no longer start regeneration of
health and shields salute no no no I
want you to think about this though no
instead grant a larger health and she'll
dump at the beginning of the dodge
instead of at the end so as time to kill
is actually going to be increasing your
kill times are gonna be faster so if you
get one tag and then you get a quick
boost of health that honestly may help
you win the fights in aid it may feel
it's may feel just as powerful because
the time to kill is getting quicker you
won't be able to hide and come back and
full fight that dodge that quick boost
may help you almost in the fight more I
don't know I'm gonna have to see but I
was like I feel like it's a proper like
change to where it's not like you know
you
get back to full and overdo it but I
still think it could be powerful which
I'm okay with I don't want them to nerve
stuff into the ground it was it was like
really really bad though so we'll see if
this honestly like is enough of a nerf
first all right I gotta get me on this
cuz dueling [ __ ] okay you are not going
to skim past worm Oscar that is the baby
tell you right now hunters do nothing
but rock worm husk right in this
deafening boy annoying and disgusting to
beating a hunter in a gunfight and they
do that damn dance and they turn around
a corner and guess what you're at a
disadvantage now because that flu shield
full health that sucked big time and
actually let's be honest I mean if
you're looking at it from a hunter's
perspective you know it's it kind of
pigeon-holed you like to go into the
crucible or whatever it's like why would
you take anything other than that you
know you don't have it you're at a
disadvantage it was like why even use
another exotic so you know we still have
to see in testing how the new way it's
gonna work with you're gonna get a
larger health pool and a shield bomb at
the beginning with that I get that is it
finite we have there's still some
questions there what least it's not as
crazy as before so I am happy I know to
do this in the chat he's very emotional
they had a good talk about this at our
talk last night and I was looking at of
laughing to the dudes tears because he's
a huddle of ziz we're of us but at the
end of the day it had to happen like it
was insane that's nothing but hunters
women and I was only exactly what and it
was just crazy specially in competitive
so frustrated but again I don't know
what sales like it may not be as nerfed
as you think honestly full shield and
full health
or maybe it's just the health you know
Kay we'll see we'll see
again you're right I have to see it in
real world action testing you know I
know my boy fall I'll probably put some
out there and you know cross and all
those guys they'll do some extensive
testing but at least it's being thought
about that's all I saw it's it's it's
change but yeah I'm kind of curious with
the ttk being faster if it's really
gonna make it you know any better for
the rest of us we'll find out warlock to
increase healing drift effectiveness
that's actually good because sometimes
you drop that thing down and not really
that much stronger so right maybe
honestly something like that on the
healing rift maybe if you drop it down
you get a little burst as well because
it takes us I can make it's a little
quicker like burst and then kind of
continuously I mean sometimes I was shot
out of just about to put the riff down
and a little animation finishes and I'm
shot and that's it I'm like yes yeah uh
and crimp our grift now increases
precision damage this thing's already
insanely strong Oh giving you range
already giving you 30% damage now
Precision's even better they're really
hyping this precision-like your TTA and
both pvp and PVE is like gonna be
quicker and honestly precision is the
key like you have to look on land in
your shots just as the dude said you
gotta lay them and I don't want to skim
over this what I love about this is for
warlocks out there let's be honest
warlocks like our crush is healing rift
we feel safe don't here if you hide it
or whatever you know to get get your
bearings in PvE or PvP but it's just
like now it's really making a compelling
argument to take empowering riff
especially when you're doing a deep
think about doing catalyst plates you
know in the hospital and that's not you
getting the extra you know stuff I'm
just thinking of shout out to my warlock
girls out here you know we run in luna
faction you know we're jumping on a
plate empowering rift you know i'm
saying it's gonna be really sick you
know warlock
they're really going hard with support
and I'm feeling it I'm digging it man
I'm really digging this you know that
the riff you know tweaks going on on
here but that's what I got to say on
that one but I'm very excited about that
empowering rift big-time exotic to
getting some changes skull of dire
ahankara
they're kind of bringing this one back
to be it's the one we talked about
before those are mine yeah it's getting
that vibe and I guess we're gonna talk
keep that our name yeah that is mine
keep no keep this exotic in mind as we
talk later because I got increased super
energy gained from nova bomb kills which
is
same way obsidian mind worked killing
high ranked enemies will grant more
super energy so he's a good balance if
you blow like a super on you know orange
bar then you're still gonna get a bigger
chunk back as like 20 throw transverse
of steps enhanced mobility I hate how
big that is
yeah yeah it's pretty vague like
mobility belly I'm glad the armor is
getting like mods and stuff like that
and hopefully those can affect more than
just anything but really those three
stats still kind of suck yeah I mean you
know they're they don't really like make
me think of how I play like do I want
grenade recharge time super recharge
time mailer those were at least specific
things don't help generally those seemed
the ones I haven't eat you still seem so
much more vague like resilience that
really helped me in PvE like ever yes
like when you get to a certain point I
mean only feel like a three you know
resilience but yeah yeah three Brazilian
sucks so you definitely not you know
four nice oh I get that you know
transverse if I agree as well are I'm
not I don't really use it you know tend
to be honest I know sprint speed now you
know that kind of helps and stuff like
that and I know as it previously worked
it would reload energy weapons so now
with this new change is saying the
equipped weapon will be automatically
well which is I guess a better change
because you know whatever is in hand you
know is getting that you're using is
getting low you know automatically so I
guess that's to change again subtle I'm
not going crazy just yet I gotta see it
him and uh you know in action that kind
of deal but interesting interesting that
they felt they needed to touch
transverses sorry I'm literally looking
at your jet but I could never see a very
long chat window why so I'm like and see
if I don't kill it so enhance mobility
after you sprint for a short time your
current equipped weapon will be
automatically reloaded that's actually
not terrible I mean it seems like one of
the weaker exotics for sure yes but if
you run around and then you get into a
fight you pull it up and it's reload at
least you're ready to go yeah
the mobility use of a warlock a little
better right is that yeah so it's a
mobility build yep
yeah Titan rally barricade no longer
requires players to take cover thank God
like cuz that's like you come on PC
people just have the macro to like
literally crouch a nun crouched like
instantly like honestly if you're just
standing behind your understanding
behind your rally barricade just keep
feeding it and that's what it's gonna do
so it's gonna work similar to the way
and this almost takes away from Luna
faction boots down like those almost
need a buff just to keep up with this
and then hunters I'm sorry you guys just
have to be with one of us you need a
buddy I'd say it again I like that I
like hunters you got it in the PvE realm
you gotta be friends with warlocks the
Titans well you got you got an option oh
good almost eight fourteen now grant
allies an over shield for a short
duration when they pass through which is
a more usable version I always it was
annoyed having to stand in the bubble
cuz you can't shoot out of it coming up
if st. 14 carries over to the new
walking suit right it could be just
specific for that yeah that's a good
point so wondering like if the new
supers are each gonna have their own
piece of exotic armor most likely is
usually that mini though like not all of
them tend to get it so I guess we'll
just have to see if it's good put on
overpower one mascot the quiet one
increase energy gain from incoming
damage when critically wounded health
will be granted from kills so nothing
too crazy there I'm trying to actually
remember what the hell that damn thing
does that's the cool looking one it's
like some chainmail thing go yeah so
grants melee grenade in class ability
energy when damaged void ability kills
grant health regeneration is currently
what it does so now it's gonna increase
the energy for all your abilities so I
mean if you just wear it and that's kind
of one of those general use ones you
might not love it for specific things
but getting all your abilities back
quicker and especially if you can stack
those mods if you stack the mods and do
this all the time you're gonna get that
pretty quick especially you know pretty
tough fight win critically wounded
health will be granted from kills that's
actually kind of cool like if you you
know barely win a fight in PvP just
kidding
so they're really trying to speed things
up in kind of sometimes subtle ways
which I like yeah definitely
grenades basically just some increased
base damage thank God for my accion's
man Oh somebody missed a typo here this
is the eye right go ahead and need to
move that indention back one please it's
literally just one no it's just funny
because they're always they they pour
over these things like six times I'm
sure I don't usually catch anything one
of the first few titles I've seen
execute mold increased base damage
increase the amount of time it takes for
the tracking strength to lessen so we'll
hunt you harder and faster for a
long-ass flashbang or damage curtain
since in your grenade more damage some
grenade more damage scatter grenade
range and fall-off ranges for the Dozen
a more reliable damage yeah scattered
terrible all remember what scatters will
actually decent you know whose val was
fun for like two minutes but yeah i'm
just hoping nothing manacles comes back
bro that was my jam see they mention
something about grenadiers getting back
to that which is what I would love cuz
right now Grenadier does squat but it
doesn't change the way I want to build
effects like Grenadier is not strong
enough for me to equip something like
shinobis Val or a world or a ability
thing over something else so hopeful
manic magnetic fusion and flux all the
ones that attach increased base damage
damn just now the same whether a target
has been stuck or simply walked over the
grenade mmm magnetic grenade now
detonates only the second time if it's
attached that makes sense the second
detonation no longer only occurs on the
grenade itself and will be applied to
each individual target hit by the
initial destination that's actually cool
that's cool magnetic nade in a group of
thrall boom boom yeah absolute thing
about PvP when people are bunched up yep
yeah if you throw it on a point you're
gonna get a double tap on both of them
which I absolutely skip grenades
increased impact of each skip drone
impact for higher damage potential which
is good sometimes those are a little
hard to get going void wall just harder
to walk through which is good mm only
thing I wish about void wall they could
change if you can have a go horizontal
or vertical in front of you
mmm make it won't link in a straight
wall to hold down the hallway or make it
a wide wall to like stop all the enemies
coming at you like make it really okay
but well no I mean like for for PvP
typically it's a hot light you know you
have paths you typically are gonna run
down yes if you have just one like
straight through of it you're not gonna
take as much damage as if you I could
literally fill up a hallway you're not
that's like shutting down a point
so right a pathway so I wish you could
at least go like some way to control the
way it landed I don't know how but it
just would be nice nice I'm way to
change it up random quality of life's
swords will have shaders this is really
cool the timer for healing rift shadow
empowering rift rally barricade just
even if your abilities when you're
wondering when's this thing gonna go
away now you know you know yeah this is
odd wanted escapees from prison of
elders will roam the open world nice
lovely I know like this is where they're
starting to like throw taken and vanilla
destiny before taking king came out
you'd start to see him in the world
exactly it's it's a great it's a great
preview and if they've had a history of
this I mean even back to house remember
the wolves are howling know that and
used to go out in the was at the cosmic
zone area and you'd see you know these
random you know the wolves out there
you'd be fighting them and stuff like
that so basically was kind of that
preludes in your current game what some
of the new DLC things will be bringing
in and I like that a lot
so good way to again like if you've got
d1 and You Raynald go patrol and there's
I don't know if there's gonna be scoring
out there or what they are but yeah
there this patch for everybody's gonna
have a whole lot behind it and increase
the difficulty of the loss sectors
example EDC will be 240 it doesn't feel
like okay I mean like who gives a fly
away but I read that I was like yeah I
was like why is that specifically a
thing I mean we're all gonna be so far
beyond this mm hmm maybe for new players
this does now I guess if you just go if
you're wandering through ebz you can't
go into lost sector an accident and
survive you would have to literally come
back after the story and do it so man I
guess and that but
go into it like walk into a loss sector
so for the world of warcraft players out
there you'll understand this go up to
like an instance make it be like a
portal or something you pass through to
start it like you'd start a mission have
a loss sector kind of be that and pick
like pick your normal say it's 240 if it
were you want a heroic loss sector put
that thing like 450 like Jack the power
level up or at least give you the option
to do it that way yeah would be nice
alright so next topic the man with the
tentacles on his face mister yes yes let
me grab you slim daddy yeah you jump on
it but that is because um I actually
don't think this is I don't think this
is getting enough credit I actually like
these changes so I'm sure I've see his
will is not his own but um yeah he will
no longer display the vendor icon on
destination maps love that um you know
just for it for a whole purpose of you
know big back to mystery right bring
back to mystery stop letting him be
attached which is the next point to
flash points and I mean it was like you
know soon as the reset happened did you
figure out what a flash point is boom
there he is and then he has a clear
purpose but cannot explain it forgive
him good joke and here's my favorite
right here oh I know this is for me
faded engrams will grant only pre
forsaken exotics thank God you love this
chain love this love and I love it for
so many reasons just for the fact that
listen exotics have to feel exotic you
know and when he came around fine
you grab whatever you have for the week
it really helps it a newer player you
know I mean as well the only time it's
gonna help us a guy like us if it is it
exotic that we just haven't got you know
but when they introduced faded in I'll
never forget that 12 meaning you did I
was like I don't know how I feel about
that because people were just sitting in
with tons of shards right you go to him
and literally you just wait one week and
you'll get the entire inventory and you
know a month and it's just like it just
cheapened exotics to me everybody had
everything and um yeah it's just one of
those things like there
the if that's gonna happen let him give
you the old stuff but the new stuff play
the game explore it have that sense of
d1 where it's like Tim haven't gotten
that yet
oh really look at you bought this in the
tower right now Tim I gotta get that you
don't say like it it was something
special about that and I felt that was
that's been lost in d2 with this give
everybody everything mode and this go to
that I love I know I ran a lot but I had
to talk about this mound I don't feel
this is getting enough shine out here
100% agree like literally I have no
qualms with this for one the hunt for it
makes it a little more fun video video
for me to do every week but also it's
like okay so it's necessary I'm just
gonna go to this tree all right I'm
gonna go to the cave on top of the ship
like I know exactly where he is like
there's no the dude is mysterious of the
nine we don't know squat about him still
don't know any lore on this dude exactly
at some point we have to figure out who
the nine are I mean Jesse 14 maybe who
knows but well I grant granted if
destiny ever wraps they better give us
something about him but dude he's not
like on a train schedule like come on he
said it rains good job Dave I mean it's
like all right at about 12 o'clock he's
gonna pull it into a tree Messer has a
right like it's it was planned in d1
you're like well he's got so many points
honestly I'd love it more if you could
move around on planets and not be in the
same damn size like give it multiple
options like you really got to go hunt
him down which is kind of a rough hunt
for me but it's like that's kind of the
whole plate like you're gonna find some
moments people are gonna start doing
some hunting this kind of takes me back
to as I was doing all the region chests
because I really had never knocked him
all out I did most all of them together
mm-hmm and there's just a little nooks
and crannies of these maps like I got
kind of surprised especially when it was
mercury like mercury had one upon the
side of the infinite forest entrance I
was surprised they put one that high
mm-hmm couple other ones that were
around there was one
in IO pulling the like upper tier the
pyramidion when you do that it really
yes yes yes back down or around like
underneath I'm like I would have never
even looked like much less even think I
could have but I was like I just kind of
jumped down and with my hunter I was
like oh and I had to catch myself and I
was like it's right there so you know
like just making everybody look a little
more and stuff like that just honestly
the appreciate I was probably it was
just going back to kind of appreciation
for some of the stuff they put into this
game that a lot of people never even
find - I'm so glad you said that
and just to double down and finish off
your point especially what you just said
there you know and let's be honest like
this gives back to the community it
gives back to the content creator cuz I
remember like I would be at work and I'm
like damn where's the bouncers video at
home yes y know when I get home I know
where service you know it now I miss
that so much that was a big part of what
destiny was you wanted to know where he
where he was and you wanted to know what
he got right like okay this week okay
this I need all he's got he's got this
this week okay cool really like you
would use hi it just adds back to that
mystery and giving content creators
those where's ur videos that's what I
miss it's like destiny like there's a
keyword like xur location' doesn't mean
squat right now we all know so yeah so I
mean honestly these are proper changes
cuz I mean sir also needs to have some
bounties he needs to have a little more
involved in his inventory there needs to
be more to his weekly arrival as opposed
to here's his exotics you can buy like
honestly we've said this before to have
it be maybe one armor and one weapon I'd
almost rather see it like you know a
faded in gram for each would not even
have like and that's it like have a new
year old don't have it be a specific
thing you can make it a gamble or not
and then maybe make it like one exotic
be it a piece of armor a weapon and just
one that you for sure know what it is
right got a couple options a roll if you
want but don't have a brain for exotics
how fast you gonna go that's good not
the number he like just pull it back
like it's just too many to me personally
so no I here we go with what I just got
last question cuz you actually knew what
about so you won just
one regardless per class as opposed to
her as it is right now with every class
is what one per class I want one oh I do
one arm one piece of armor for some
class and if you don't play it maybe
it's an incentive play that class
then or a weapon like okay but that
takes that brings the exotic back to
exotic no I'm with you I'm not I'm just
yes uh-huh no I see what you're going
with it I guess you know that the the
the people who are new to destiny
wouldn't like that but for us hardcore
yes because that extends the life of
exotics during expansion you know okay
so new players do you really want me to
hand you everything or do you still want
to visually get there but I got I got I
got a stick up for them on this one
point I remember you know just start now
sir was a big help during like my very
early destiny career like you know
sometimes you do get unlucky you know
everyone's got you you're not powerful
enough really to do much you get your
first kind of exotic it kind of gives
you your bearings you know I'm saying
you you get your little training wheels
you go outside you can bike with the big
boys now
alright so I get it you know saying and
I just I just I don't want to eliminate
them completely because I know how it is
sometimes it I remember D when I it was
very hard man to get something you know
and that's how it should be that's
literally like if okay so tell me this
I'm a new player I go and I Cesar for
the first week sweetheart I got four
exotics mm-hmm that's way too damn many
and takes like it takes the fields out
of those exotic drops even so even if
you say that experience for for some to
make it feel more valuable down the road
yeah they're gonna get a little boost in
the front but then once they have
anything what the hell's the grant what
is left to grind so you're making
perfect that's the only thing I may
disagree with you is you also want the
arm the elimination of per class as a
poll you you just like one either weapon
or one armor so let's just say I'm a
warlock and it's a hunter then
like czars useless to me yeah that way
he's like yep so what fine maybe one
just random in Graham that you could buy
with shards so like one random roll of
whatever and then maybe one specific one
that you know you can buy to give you an
option for something but then like one
set things I just don't want to see four
set things a week that's too many
because in four weeks I'm gonna see them
all so that's why you're okay with the
fated well maybe that we are our common
place could be the fate of Ingram be
having the old stuff so then the new
player can say okay you know what I got
enough shards or whatever the currencies
gonna be if they can continue that and
say alright let me just get me afraid of
ingria and then no I could rock with you
now I'm seeing when you come from so I
mean it'd just be a way to yeah it's
exotics need to feel that way and that's
my worry generally is when everybody
gets them too quick
so having four from him personally is
too many they didn't have I mean they
had four and destiny one I know but I
still thought that was kind of too many
the weapons took a while to go through
but that's just my thoughts anyway lots
of I mean good things you gotta go hunt
for him and he's not just gonna throw
all the new stuff at you positive across
the board there so - you just need to
point oh wow yes coming so destiny
players will no longer be able to log
into destiny it's gonna be taken offline
for like a 15 minute mate in so parently
they're gonna roll out the update
maintenance will remain offline so come
the 28th I'm gonna be able to get home
from work and then about 4 p.m. then
you're gonna get to play and test the
stuff stuff out honestly my field this
is a bigger downtime than the other one
yeah then Forsaken I think this is going
to be your bigger content download and
then for a seconds gonna be the switch
right this is like 4 hours down
maintenance all that stuff they're doing
from 7 to 10 they're doing less time
down next the week after so yeah
spend some time make sure it's
downloaded make sure your systems on
have your life like touch a button make
sure it does it does what it needs to do
like whatever you got to do make sure
but we get a little preview of system
changes in update 2.0 so in this one so
as you guys know 2.0
going to handle the weapon slots this is
one of the biggest things we get to see
bolts face you know Bullock's shader
deletion that stuff's coming but weapon
slots are changing certain weapons are
going to certain spots forever certain
things are gonna lock in to specific
places so basically look over this
specifically if you have any question of
what's coming
read this one for yourself cuz I'm gonna
try and skim it cuz I've probably said
this twice already
yeah there are certain weapons for year
one there to go into kinetic slots like
silicon neuroma the Hawthorne shotgun
they're gonna be kinetic period so you
can't use kinetics there but it's gonna
probably still an energy weapon the I
close is gonna be locked to solar
straight up because they just don't want
that pair to tractor cannon to ruin
stuff which is fine correct they know
when things are gonna be tube ridiculous
yeah I mean back to Canada is already
insane so it's track to cannon will glow
shotgun and trench barrel
oh boy like those combinations on bosses
and stuff like that with different
people like yeah it gets we we melt in
an escalation protocol like that I was
like part of the flow it was crazy
you're one exotics will remain in the
power slot as exceptions to year to
weapon slot changes darcy legend of a
curious tractor camera whisperer the
worm mm-hmm that makes sense I mean what
those are capable of shutting down a
super adding void damage led avid legend
of a curious has to stay like it yeah
there's no way you go legend actually
run around like bar see when you lock on
I mean for a powerup and slot like Darcy
is good enough to fit there still and
whisper as well so I mean those four
they finally have actually put the word
whisper the worm on one of these I think
that's the first time I've actually seen
this yeah absolutely
and let's not forget the fact that the
other exotics are moving think about
yeah no I'm actually thinking what's in
there wow fused a colony colony in
energy merciless unless though Telesto
in the grenade was that prospector on
what else we got oh this is the one I
want to talk to you about I was thinking
about the flashbang mm-hmm what happens
to ward Clif kreidel it's a rocket
launcher still a little stay but he is
the sentence all right you make sense I
would agree with that no rocket
launchers are staying well they did say
okay I just want the mess because I'm
like if Kayla's running around in would
have been scary okay all other year one
energy and power weapons will have their
elements will attribute locked for your
too so if you have a man a nun and you
have an Orioles gift whatever you have
it's gonna stay that way play the game
doesn't matter it's gonna lock in now
honestly mmm it's probably not gonna
matter that much once you get farther
into forsaken if you want to have
certain options for you know shields or
I like my minions I'm gonna have all
three of those just as I'm going through
but random roles honestly you're
probably gonna Trump basically anything
you've seen in year one because better
devils can be better devils and then
better so whatever it like I mean
whatever you've got now it can only
improve with a mod and a masterwork and
everything else so it's likely only
going to improve so what you've got now
is probably gonna be a holdover so even
if you don't lock everything perfectly I
wouldn't worry too much about it but if
there's certain ones you love go for it
mm-hmm a new animal economy will be live
so that's the big one I've got to see
I'm still curious how they're gonna
balance this out and I'm wondering if
this is like a mo economy 0.9 maybe
there's like a day one patch for
Forsaken where they like adjust yeah
because I have a hunch it's not quite
gonna fit feel right yeah but especially
trying to you know be to place this with
certain build you know I mean yeah like
three shotguns when they start with four
bullets like I know they don't want it
overpowered but it seemed real small
yeah yeah we got to see we got to see
you know cuz you know how does it apply
it with the economy you know you've got
technically you know um three shotguns
one you know a couple of stuff that used
to be power and special you know it's
gonna be interesting it's probably one
of those things that I think may end up
not
is practical really that practical once
we get the whole system down but again
we've got that week you know Tuesday to
test to see how these things work out
and that that to me is the key so I'm
very excited about the change though cuz
I already got some builds in my head
that I'm thinking about running with I
just can't wait to have snot like
silicone we're almost actually pretty
decent PV throw that in my kinetics lot
with I like Sun shot in the middle oh
that's when we're like I here we go I'm
thinking about perfect paradox right now
oh you love that one yeah I love that
good I'm saying I'm a zenith in paradox
do before I close came out so yeah I'm
excited for paradox beginning and what
that's gonna do you know so yes a lot
it's a lot of bills whether you get a
chance to play with and just that it's
gonna feel powerful you know it's really
gonna feel powerful in certain things
having you know a power style a weapon
or even a fusion style weapons in the
slot and you know you're gonna have more
versatility with your load I was going
into encounters oh yeah I mean that's I
mean I know PvP is gonna be completely
broken for a little while which is a
game but I also just like the fact that
PvE I'm gonna have an option to be like
scout scout scout sniper rocket like I
mean you know picking stuff off turn
over here hit this guy in the head with
a sniper and still have a backup power
weapon yeah that's not just a sniper
oh but like I mean ah but also pulling a
shotgun out too I hardly use those
things and sometimes I mean those are at
a pretty good spot when you actually
choose to use them I just took over
power I mean things like whisper or
rocket launchers I mean there's stuff
that's just so good right get myself to
use it
exactly exactly I totally go from exotic
weapons
so basically collections you've got
right now armors emblems exotics things
like that you're not gonna be able to
touch your collections so if you do need
something for the next week come the
28th get it now if you want to
experimental stuff having your inventory
delete you can delete some of your
legendary supposedly they'll come back
that's up to you but I was like you'll
have your you know vault space coming so
if you fill up everything the one thing
about this they have said some things
are going to move around so if you have
all of your power weapons that are going
to
come kinetics kinetics are full they are
going to dump in your postmaster make
sure your postmaster is empty and make
sure you have space for things to move
put them in your vault and make sure you
have space in your postmaster so if
nothing's move around you're not going
to lose anything that's the basically
make sure you have space but nothing is
lost that's great advice
tooltips may not quite be working right
on a few things fine I don't care
exotic weapons will lose their +5 power
mods just because all the plus fives are
going away that's going away and we're
one arm row mods will be deprecated
entirely starting September 4th
nightfalls will not feature strike
scoring until 9 4 as well so no reason
to run a prestige next week
so be it yeah that's done they did say
prestige or trials the 9 we know it's on
a hiatus but they also said the trophy
achievement is just not gonna happen for
a little while oh yes serious this is
false this armor if you are still
grinding out they have a couple tips
about that but basically finish it
before the 28th you can master work it
after the 28th because you'll actually
have the armor to do the effect but we
need to finish the getting the legendre
armor if you want to so but other than
that got a couple cinematics top scorers
there out in games come right now if
you're out on the other side of the
world play some gambit if you're gonna
go pax west go play some gambit yeah of
it seriously like if you can get your
hands on and you're gonna be out there
anyway try it like I'm envious no I know
now one more little topic we can tease
at because I don't want to break this
thing for everybody yes there's a pretty
substantial leak out there about what is
to come mm-hmm now if you guys will
avert your eyes real fast do not
broadcast on my cell by the way the
story the twitch finally just and I
think you did the funniness with you you
would you know Google gets stupid hold
on let me see if I can scream
sure and on-screen sure you say it that
made me kick it in
okay guys always gets [ __ ] but if
not support which broadcast we advise
when you should be subscribed you need
I'm sorry guys because I didn't say
anything
exactly I didn't type in chat yeah we
figured out why it does it is all right
make sure you got stuff open so I'm not
gonna put it on screen but basically
there is a leak out there it's your
option to go read it but the idea kind
of what we were saying is it really does
feel without saying too much about it
campaign leads into endgame mm-hmm
motivation behind it and the things
going on actually really seem to link
pretty well together
the names those somewhat of the lore
behind a couple of these things sound
like really really cool stuff so I'm
trying not to say very much because I
obviously don't want to ruin it for you
guys but just the look of some things
they've got some teasers out there about
strike names just the actual possible
more behind the raid name itself which
they do list that yes it's called last
wish mm-hmm
shout out to life always doing some good
videos thing about some of the stuff
that he loves doing or hoping for in
this game they're made the creature they
talk about in the little you know teaser
video they did maybe an epic fight all
I'm gonna say it's gonna be kind of
amazing if they pull that off the way
I'm hoping for yes says in my mind it it
could be a really tight room if it's all
fight yeah like you can go taking King
more it's more open but if it's in the
core of us that no but I also love it's
like I mean so you're going 400 to 600
power level what do you think the soft
cap is gonna be I'm kind of curious
Oh 400 to see the largest gap we've had
mm-hmm so this is not this is you know
there's no president with this is tough
man
you figure all right let's start with
what we but what I think we may know
right
the really has to be five something
right Oh a must yeah like there's no way
you do a normal rate lower than 500 out
of max but I would you 550 they may do
it maybe watch love to see 560 so the
prestige you can't do without like going
from like [ __ ] you to be more than 50
levels below right I'd like to see that
like 50 60 60 might be a round number so
you get that fifty and one so go ahead
yeah I mean it's this is tough because
you go like 450 but because I was like
yeah like if you go 450 soft cap to get
to six still gonna be crazy like I mean
that's why it's gonna be challenging you
got powerful but the resets are coming
soon or to remember those powerful
engrams are gonna be like four days
right will have like three chances I
think before the raid goes but right you
don't figure out the balance in there I
don't want to be too small right uh and
then they have to know it's got to be
capable but you like the raid is
actually gonna give you a level up when
you do it
I don't like you to be like 500 in it's
500 and you're like I'm just getting
stuff to sorry I want it to like you
know when you were 30 and you did the
raid stuff when Playgirl vanilla you got
31 gear you got a boost yeah based on
what we know my guests will probably be
like that 450 475 range only for the
simple fact is not a time remember
remembering past 12 that we've done
right if you remember when they were
talking about exotics and leveling up
they will everything was very helpful
you know things that gave you exotics
that you know at that level will give
more like everything was very generous
towards light so the vibe I'm getting is
hey soft cat maybe smaller right but at
least once you get there it's not the
complete over reliance on powerful
activities because that's what it is now
like you have to do those that powerful
gear tab once you hit soft cat because
everything else was not giving you
anything but everything else is giving
you something whether even if it's a one
light Plus grind so that makes me infer
that the grind is long if they're being
that generous you see where I'm going
absolutely yeah I mean you've got a 500
strike playlist but they want the people
to like they wanted people to be able to
work up into that not just like be done
with the campaign and go to 500 actually
and now that we know what we know about
raid 8 and if they are confident about
pushing it out back a week then yeah
maybe yeah maybe they'd go 550 lives in
595 50 you know by the time next week
maybe guys are like 500 525 or whatever
and then those dosed rewards then help
you get towards those regulars didn't
help me get towards a 600 but it's still
gonna take a while so yeah I'm going
with that you know 525 550 range for the
raid for the raid sorry I'm soft cap for
you know 450 475 ish okay yeah I mean
that's I'm probably on the same boat
somewhere like yeah 522 550 for the raid
somewhere in there so it's above 500 and
that's gonna take some work but maybe if
you're like 500 from some of the strikes
you might be like 501 you're under it
we're gonna benefit from doing it even a
decent boost if it's like hard enough to
be like you finish you get one piece of
like you know five thirty gear and
you're like ooh that's a cool boost cuz
I was like 502 we'll start helping you
in little pieces but like I may be tough
but if you finish it a big boost and
that's what I write so that's what they
said they said those type of activities
should be more of a substantial boost if
they're giving out those level of boosts
grind to get to 6:00 is gonna be long so
I think the smoke the soft cap is
smaller so we're just to see how our
prediction go when we get the official
patch notes yeah seriously so we've got
four strikes those will be at least fun
to have in a rotation nice more things
to learn and yeah but like I want to
know how gambit falls into all this like
leveling even and it's got its own
infamy system in the bow it's linking
and that's got where if you're like you
know you've done your couple things for
a day we'll go grind out some you know
gimmicks like bounties all over the
place
Nannan so close I can't wait for it then
it's like wow yeah it's so cool I'm just
excited about weapon changes right now
like next week like we're getting refuge
it's going down you know they're like
I'm gonna get the player yeah had a
question actually from plummy
sure what d1 are exotic do you want or
miss the most
alright this is a two-part question for
me um shot up th chromes um the first
would be I'm gonna say the first one is
gonna be pertaining to the theme that I
want is pertaining to the theme of
forsaken which is in the reef and my
favorite I know where you're going you
don't listen I am Lord Cognito
forget I don't forget anything Lord
related y'all you're my one of my
favorite was the Lord of wolves I had
somehow figured out how to master it I
mean it was a beast in PvE
you know it was acting like a kind of
like a short-range pulse but if you hit
all the shots especially their precision
it would just melt I love that thing
then he gave the support it basically
went around the theme of how the Fallen
wolves act they come in packs so when
you get a kill you support your
teammates with that plus whatever it was
resilience or whatever it was right so
love that thing and in pv p that was the
that gun i went to the lighthouse with
Lord of wolves dude
that's how good I was with that gun like
I just knew the ranges how to use it and
it I was a support player like I wasn't
the most the people that got me to lie I
was like those my crannies but they were
they were superstars but my thing was
shut supers down shut whatever down you
know be aggressive oh man how's my baby
now to the first the other part which is
like which D one man there's so many
good words right now I'm like this this
is tough you know um mmm everybody knows
the basics you know I don't want to say
that the normal stuff you know truth you
know mmm
and to be honest I can't even save X
because I got vexed got my first of X I
hate you trying so I can damn this is
tough thinking you know what last word
was my baby yeah I never I sucked with
that gun I'll just be straight-up honest
killed at that one honestly it was a
really popular thing in the meta but if
you were last word I respected it
because as bad as I was with it I knew
how good they were with it yeah last
word man I was that's what when I first
got destiny I fell in love with hand
cannons that was one of the ones I
picked because I mean when you first
start you have to pick a weapon so I
tried Halleck hand cannon and then one
of the early exotics I got was last word
and just a whole the lore behind it the
animation how he flicked that you know
I'm saying the trigger yeah and then
that's when people are wondering if it's
coming back because it hits way too
close to home - all that stuff hits her
eels with wild you know this is a
Western tale so let me bring it back to
you that was a great question in the
chat what about you good morning cryptic
as well cryptic there's all you guys in
chat par 5 over in the YouTube everybody
little warning though for me if we're
definitely since we definitely were
talking about weapons since you kind of
went with two yeah kinda I couldn't
throw doubles out that's how bad I
wanted yeah so one for me just because
of its unique feel and what it was
capable of mm-hmm you're like you have
no idea where I've no idea what you go
I'm like I'm like a 10 strongly
attentively listening dark drinker wow
you're so it's good because of the way
because of what it was capable of and
how it truly fit the word exotic yeah
that spin was capable of and how much
ammo they held and just the nature of
the exotic swords in general but that
was the one that I think had the best
coolest like animation and everything to
go with it as one now for one that I
probably used a lot more than I ever
should have been just loved the way the
ping on it is you know what I'm saying
oh yeah when you hear that sound uh-oh
some odd numbers it's a sexy looking gun
like that I love oh oh and that gun look
- that gun was sexy like it was just you
know unfortunately I was on the Xbox at
that time and unfortunately I didn't
only fortunately the god PlayStation
role we never experienced it but what
was it like a magic bullet right it
would just be it would be the praça of
all 300 basically you have luck in the
chamber so one random bullet causes
considerable bonus damage holding aces -
more random bullets but it was just the
occasional one time in a clip all three
would proc and it was just BAM now I
don't even know if I really probably got
more than maybe one or two of those like
triple proc hills but you had three
bullets in there which was enough in a
fairly long clip it had 13 but the range
in the way that gun Oh Oh like that was
that was one of mine that I probably
used a lot more than I should have got
to give a small runner up to
bad juju because of all because of what
it would do for your super house it
would and that's literally and this is
the one where I miss the builds for like
person about this is super bonus is like
okay is so like what's my spec for the
week it is straight-up bad juju no
question because every seal is gonna
build my super getting yes all those
compound together those are the ones who
I want things that help builds yes
remember it was a warlock it was bad
juju in a city in my comp oh oh oh that
I was that was dirty scream Oh Bailey
try to get you apparently you were
sleeping question that's why I wanted to
bring it up so that's a great question
yeah a Chronos has got Queen breakers
bro that's another one that was pretty
cool I took skill that was like the
charging fusion travel time and all that
stuff so but there was some cool ones in
there I definitely did enjoy and then
there were ones that in theory sounded
cool than they ever turned out to be
like Zen meteor theory sucked after all
like you never got to use that thing but
on the other side Plan C I miss my baby
see I was a god about that oh yeah and
then of course the one will never see
again my thunder casting Thunder Lord
[Applause]
Lord
yeah that was a classic classic man so
the par 5 I do not want to see the toy
cup that was terrifying dude two tabs
walk away oh and the burn damage just
exposing where you are on the map oh no
thank you
it was sexy though it was say I can't
feel like don't look like a cause that
number oh yeah Lauren was good yeah
so it was like there's there's
definitely some good stuff that I mean
things like the first Kirsten Ace of
Spades those were pretty lackluster in
general so I mean there were hitter
misses in that department too there's
some that we absolutely loved and their
son that I'm like nemesis starved me
yeah it's like that was like some not
all are gonna be winners and I like how
they kind of keep breaking the exotics
we've got in a good way
yes so I hope that trend continues is
all I gotta say I mean you can go
through and oh we might do armor on our
next one maybe save that for next week
just to see about some dy like that yeah
you want armor hype so kind of keep that
in mind see what your favorites were and
we'll discuss those again as well you
got anything else I know we're kind of
chats actually bumping right now so not
much but um yeah you got me I can't wait
for next week bags you gotta be in this
whole memory lane you know for uh you
know favorites favorites and stuff and
yeah I'm very hyped I can already think
of some forearm you know as far as our
exotic arms for next week that we can
talk about yeah yeah so I don't know man
we've got the proper time for the raid
like ten days is reasonable for a
dungeon raid by the way heads up today's
National awful day on Twitter so we've
got the test coming we've got the gambit
actual like freebie demo which is cool
we've got the weapon slot so you got
your like it's like the perfect just
like the time cadence of all this stuff
seems to do they like nail art on it I'm
trying to tell you man that marketing
team like I said say what you want I
know me and you had our little issues
with the whole cave reveal but say what
you want this lead-up is probably one of
the best lead ups to in expansion they
have done in a long walk because I'm
trying to even think about taking try to
remember taking I know we were hype I
know we saw each other's I know they had
information but this just seems I don't
know if it's me it just seems week to
week there was something else going on
that you're still playing that's new it
was Soulstice it was this now it's that
mode I did bring in
and comes in and then boom you know here
we go you know free you know what you
call gambit then we got holes you know
guess what
one week you know ahead of time boom
weapon slots it's just something to log
in and do and then even before that
whisper came out so think about in a
period of like a month and a half every
single week in destiny there has been
something fun and exciting to do and
they are nailing then you throw the
gunslinger the last gunslinger trailer
you get the fuse going for caveman shout
out to the marketing team they don't get
enough credit man this is fantastic job
of just leading into this expansion I'm
ready I'm pumped let's go seriously like
me too I mean those guys they know how
to do it they know exactly what people
want to see they I was like me having
like having this cinematic still for me
would have more weight in the moment for
the first time but for the game for what
needed to happen
I've never argued that like it needed
the the hype it needed the bill that
needed this game but it needed the
cinematic that's like epic 4k like all
those things needed to happen oh you
ripped me down yeah I know I said it
didn't I know you all fight I'll get to
take though maybe go back at age five
you know I was like no for me I was like
I would say it was like I wish they
wouldn't have because for me the reveal
would feel more weight of course but I
would almost like but from the status
that the game was in they had to people
go like I'm sorry what just happened
like they needed that moment to meet
people's interest and kind of really
start reeling a batfish back in so no I
was like I mean I'll let you finish I'm
sorry go ahead
no no I'll just say until their credit
now we're seeing with the last
gunslinger trailer what they showed it
III was like I said it was just a tone
piece it didn't happen that way so now
I'm even more excited of you know
everything again that really leads up to
that and the whole thing so yeah man
then just angry to you like no we got
get him we gotta get them like you know
it is this is just really good marketing
and the I think that the testament to it
will be after we finish the campaign you
know how can we get Aldrin and then what
you know then you know me and you
already have some discussions offline
about tech you don't know an answer but
I mean spoiler but you know we're not
gonna talk about that now but at the end
of the day is just like man this is this
is exciting
oh and one last thing that we didn't get
a chance to talk about was um did you
see I believe I've got who put the tweet
out here's the funny - he was like size
doesn't matter but this is impressive
and they showed the the physical hard
drive size of both taken King and now
forsaken I believe like 46 no no no
again size and everything but at the end
of the day it's like man that's a lot
you know I mean you have to world sure
you know tinkle chores gonna have a
whole lot of stuff to do it's Wheaties a
story you're gonna do a lot of
adventures there like most of the store
will be there then you'll dabble into
that but there's still gonna be reasons
to come back absolutely are both is
gonna be yeah it's gonna be late so much
to do yeah that's now going to chat
what's going on bro your screams like
yeah 18 versus 40 yep this is huge man
this is huge and again I think they even
have um shelter unknown players gotta
figure out right now you know that
there's one of the the dread-nots ships
this crash-landed in I believe the
tangled Shore
call me from yeah and I mean I can see
ya know they've already shown it like
they did the Game Informer has the
footage of us you know guardians running
around in one of those ships because
remember even though the dread-nots
itself was the largest in scale yeah
there are a bunch of little mini ones
like the little dreadknots was still big
so I guess you know one was shot down
and then it ended up being there on the
wall complaint so this is gonna be
interesting as well to explore that area
you know you're gonna have the hive
running around in there you know so I'm
excited I'm excited man it just seems
again not to get too crazy but just all
the way around they seem to be on the
ball with this
and now it's just matter of just driving
this baby home and executing so I'm Liam
hi I just want to come in and say I saw
the Forsaken trailer and the fields oh
my god the fields oh yeah absolutely
yeah it's kind of crazy
in a really really good way so then we
could just keep rambling on just like
there's there's so much good stuff
coming but yeah it was like how how much
exploring how if there's do you think
there's going to be like memory
fragments like they did or my gosh
there's gonna be like all of that stuff
is you know wait no so much so much I'm
just bouncing up and down to my chair
right now idiot so oh yeah shy too tight
I can't even talk so we so excited this
morning both you guys thank you it's
just fun a little commentary as we go
through definitely I put it up but I
think we can start wrapping it up we're
wrapping here close to our good old hour
and a half is where we're trying to keep
it I'm doing like a 2 plus anymore this
is it's funny how we actually talk
offline though and it's the times where
we like we have this you know 12 to
cover we have this full article and then
we finished on like an hour in 5 minutes
so they just we've had just at swab and
we get off on ramblings and we're like
we could keep going go but thank you
guys for always tuning in times for both
if you guys have seen my a couple new
videos on my channel I finally got my
logo and animation done it's really high
dude I was happy how that turned out
because the the logos like okay blocking
it in I'm gonna have the banner set and
I asked the animation guys like what can
you do the Cheetahs like yeah I just
have a running crashing below he did I
was like dude just change the colors and
I'm set cuz he had it like purple and
blue before his like just give me that
yellow and green crash and it was like
this because I had joked with you before
I was like I did not want the bouncing
techno name logo and I got something
that's unique for me and I was really
really happy with it so if you guys have
seen it if not just check out one of my
videos
it's yeah it's short and sweet if you
guys get tired of it I'll try and mix it
up a little bit but yeah other than that
you guys know where to find me it's
Twitter Avant is twitch TV where I'm at
right now if you guys already follow me
if not hit
follow button at least just you guys
will know when I go live doing these and
other things there's gonna be a lot of
twitch probably when it comes to
forsaken yes and then YouTube subscribe
like comment all the good stuff you guys
know it's just the little stuff like
that actually does help us out more than
you guys probably know YouTube's really
funky with it stuff so just any love we
get from you guys it's always always
appreciated that's pretty much all I got
I mean pontus everywhere it's easy yeah
of course it is at Lord Cognito man
every Sunday is the Lord's Day please
tune in this Sunday we will have mooch
from the crossfire podcast with me
talking some games and stuff like that
and that will be live we go live on the
inner circle network there and that is
Sundays at 1:00 p.m. Eastern check us
out talk about high platform gaming and
of course here on the iron log podcast
channel you have flashpoint as well as
other original content as we go to
trading shows III packs and all the like
would put a lot of footage up there
interviews please check those things out
as well really appreciate the support
like a you want to said and on Twitter
I'm at lower kognito
at Xbox if you're on xbox we got a big
flourishing destiny clan iron what
podcast clan we really helped each other
out we try to sharper we do raids you
know there's there's something for
everyone to do and as long as you're
active you know please hit us up on our
podcast again on xbox and yeah man
that's what I got PlayStation Xbox 360
and I know soon PC was coming advances
will try his uh his indoctrination at
that point so I can get into the realm
of 60 frames a second 1440 I got 4k HD
Ottawa hold it on hold it over 4k 30
alright interlaced and checkerboard
that's pro bro that's Brodie axis yeah I
was gonna say I want you to put an Xbox
one X next year new PC and then you tell
me which one looks better because that
was like PC master-race
4/5 is like comments now like you know
why don't you play in ps1 ps4 anymore is
like honestly
for one I love mouse and keyboard and
the way the hand cannons feel in this
game on PC are solid so I mean that's
one of those that is really hard to tear
away from but to like once you've had it
as pretty as it is on here because there
are certain effects on PC that you
literally don't get fax fax like just if
there's more power there's more room to
compute things so just even like them
like not trying on not lighting which it
really looks cool the volumetric
lighting looks awesome particle effects
is the word I'm looking for
particle effects in that game when your
supers and you're in third person holy
crap like my mom doesn't compare dude
it's not even a question it doesn't pay
just that I'm personally trying to stay
ignorant because I know if I see that I
need to stay in my little bubble it act
like it doesn't exist
oh that's all I try and be one of those
people who keeps up with six characters
I'm like oh no I can't do that like I
was like I've just grinded out my hunter
to get him up and ready so he's about
340 once I finish the Soulstice armor
it'll be a nice kind of it's actually
nice thing if you start a new character
and you grind out your Soulstice armor
and it was lower you'll go in at a
pretty high level which is nice so it's
a good way to wrap it up that's like all
we got guys I hate that we always kind
of get this thing going whatever but for
you to be able to have a chance to sleep
and kind of four-hour day but you guys
will always be able to check this out
afterwards so if you don't check it out
leave a comment say hey hit us up on
Twitter just feel like hey podcast ask
us questions - yes wait if you can't do
that really helps you yeah tweet the
podcast really really helps us big-time
yeah but if you guys never want to hear
anything have a specific topic that was
actually really good from plumbing so if
you guys have like you know those times
we kind of wrap up have that last 10
minutes like ask us some questions on
Twitter like you let's get some
questions the week going from you guys
because I really want to get you guys
involved so we can answer what you want
to hear because I mean we know what we
talked about but generally we also want
to answer some questions that we may not
think about for you guys absolutely yeah
you want to wrap it up I'll let you kind
of finish it up and everybody okay
everybody enjoy their day we got
great content on the way two days gonna
be lit I haven't changes everything is a
good time for dancing and getting me a
place in games just we can have some fun
everyone enjoyed a day and on that note
we are a man piece out of here like
Vladimir now we have an awesome day have
an awesome weekend if you grind it a lot
you can breathe but test the weapons
slots but September 1st finds order some
pizza
plop yourself down and enjoy some gambit
facts do you guys have a good one